when you think about i get paid on a
friday but my rent is due on wednesday
that doesn't seem like a big deal to
even say well i could be a couple days
late but if you're a mother on a
marginal income
saving to keep great credit so that you
can afford to buy a house that two days
could make all the difference in your
credit score that makes all the
difference whether you're able to secure
a loan or not
hey i'm michael render professionally
known as killer mike
[Music]
i've grown up in atlanta in an all-black
enclave i grew up in a neighborhood
called the carrier heights it was
founded in 1948
by black people four black people
i wore this pendant today because my
grandmother's on it my grandmother
taught me to bank she taught me how to
balance a checkbook they were always
adamant about not only having a large
bank account they also made sure that we
kept a local black bank account because
it was black banks and credit unions
that helped finance black mortgage help
finance black car loans that helped
finance the community we lived in
so my enthusiasm for banking period and
saving coin is i've seen what it has
been able to do in my own
one of the family problems that we're
facing in working-class neighborhoods
african-american and non-latino
communities of poor and working-class
white communities is a lack of
accessibility to physical banks
and many of the places that took the
place of banks were
check cashing places but they start
putting higher interest loans out there
for things charging people up to 20 just
to cash checks and greenwood and its
card was a way
to to fight that to combat that to
reverse that
i've known andrew young for 31 years
he's been an amazing ambassador for my
city and state and african americans and
in the american people and he's someone
who um i just trust
and he wanted to help this new
generation of people become more
financially responsible
poor people born with an opportunity
educational wise in a country like this
and the opportunity to take control of
coin can grow into the working class and
up into the middle class my wife and i
own the swag shop the shave washing room
shop if i went to one of the bigger
banks they're thinking you're going by
barbershop you're probably only getting
booth rent why would we lend you money
if i was the lender i think like that
but
i don't realize there's a large bank
this is a barbershop but it's also
growing out of the black community black
guys get their hair cut every week so if
i'm looking at a customer i'm looking at
a customer spending one to two hundred
dollars with me a month if i'm starting
to look at ten customers that's two
grand a month you know my bank greenwood
and smaller black banks see the need for
that they understand that eight barber
shops like eight liquor stores and
churches can co-exist in a black
community and none of them go out of
business
if you have a strong african-american
community if you have a strong latino x
community if you have a strong
working-class white community what you
have is a bunch of communities that make
for a tapestry that when strong together
make for an amazingly warm quilt that
helps keep this nation thriving and on
the forefront of the world economy
this is a 100 year campaign this is not
a 10-month campaign this is long after
i'm gone i'd like to see greenwood
growing and doing exactly what it was
named for it was named for a part of
tulsa oklahoma in which newly freed
people began and set up their own
community and i think the greatest honor
we could do those people is to make sure
that we're doing the same in the digital
space right now
[Music]